The answer is 8.
Let's go through it together to see why.
Sentence only has one re-write rule.
These are sometimes called "production rules" as well.
Only one production rule. Only one thing to do with it.
We're always going to get started with optional adjective followed by subject
followed by verb.
This could go to accurate or nothing.
The subject could go to William or Tell.
The verbs could go to shoots or bows.
We have two choices here, two choices in the middle, and two choices at the end.
When we multiply that out, we get eight possibilities--
accurate William shoots, accurate William bows, accurate Tell shoots,
accurate Tell bows, William shoots, William bows,
Tell shoots, Tell bows--eight possibilities in total.
William Tell was a 15th century Swiss folk her.
Famously, he did not bow.
He was requested to bow to the hat of a city leader or some such.
In exchange, he was asked to shoot--or offered to shoot--the apple off of his son's head,
using a crossbow. This is not a crossbow.
At least two of the sentences above--William Bows, Tell bows,
accurate William bows, accurate Tell bows--four of them didn't happen
as far as the story goes.
Even if you're not familiar with this story, you may have heard the overture.
It's actually quite a bit of fun.